[Musique]
le général tôt fait saliver encore très
populaire dans les restaurants chinois
les épiceries
sans parler des innombrables recettes
sur le web il a même fait l'objet d'un
film documentaire à la recherche du
général tao
pourquoi on aime tant générale des eaux
je pense que parce que la sauce
générateur du monde connait on mange des
choses que quand entraîné les quatre ça
va ensemble le sucré le salé le legs et
le pic
c'est pour ça que ça fait une parfaite
harmonie et voilà que les versions vegan
fonte aussi fureur en compagnie de
suzanne et de jean-philippe nous allons
explorer deux versions bonjour la
mission de jean philippe créer des
versions végétarienne de plats connus
grâce à lui le tofu est entré dans bien
des foyers québécois au québec on aime
le général tôt on aime le poulet général
tao fait que c'est beaucoup plus facile
invega nisand une recette que notre
famille connaît déjà que en inventant
quelque chose de complètement farfelu on
change l'âpreté on change le poulet pour
du tofu on change de poulet pour du
tempo on change le poulet pour des pois
chiches puis comme ça on réussit à
convaincre sa famille à manger le pois
chiche c'est le plus simple parce qu on
ouvre la boîte de conserve pour les
gueux depuis on le met dans les recettes
[Musique]
c'est la sauce qui fait le général gao
elle comporte quatre ingrédients clés le
sucre et du sirop d'érable le salé de la
sauce soya l'aigre du ketchup et pour le
pique un de la sauce ch'ti scratch c'est
ce qu'annonce très pimentée j'ai étudié
la cuisine - en asie j'ai découvert la
boxe utilisent ces quatre saveurs le
pour les pour balancer l'acidité d'un
pleut on ajoute un petit peu de sucre et
puis un petit peu de sa vie même si peu
de piquant
ça fait le nude facteurs comme on dit en
anglais ça fait le combinaison parfaite
est parvenu par un petit but est
beaucoup moins grand que le fameux tous
les parce que le poulet épargné mais
quoi donc
ici on met à peu près 2 cuillères à
soupe d'huile c'est tout est ce qu'on
peut parler d'un plat simple quand on
continue à mettre sur scène 40 gobain
on n'accepte pas les mouches avec du
vinaigre nous sommes à gramat il faut
quand même si on veut que les enfants
aiment se font un jeu de catch up
parcimonieusement explique sirop
d'érable parcimonieusement mais le plat
général tao est il vraiment chinois
vraiment ça n'existe pas dans notre
cuisine est simple à qui fait pas un
chinois dans les états unis alors
s'explique man amérique est donc louis
froment avec sucrées comme ça oui c'est
un mec est et moi aussi changent la
cheffe suzanne new travaille depuis plus
de 30 ans à faire découvrir ici la
cuisine asiatique
elle prépare sa recette avec le fus
soyeux légèrement free nous on off ça
parce que je voudrais les gens essayer
notre tofu asiatique par le tofu qui
connaît dans nos supermarchés
c'est au foot réa soyeux ça contient
beaucoup d'eau
quand vous prenez tofu avec les textures
de feta s'apprend pas la sauce de
général temps et avec le tofu soyeux 7e
bien la sauce
le tofu soyeux demandent plus
d'attention et de minutie car il est
plus fragile que sa recette diffèrent
très peu de sel ou poulet le chouchou ce
qui est pas exact il n'y a pas de pas
nue avec mes tofu il faut mettre dans le
futur et pout jusque et rendu un peu
question autour de tofu vous avez mis
votre sauce qui étaient déjà préparés
c'est déjà réduit comme à 50% au lieu de
10 mètres des picots de mélisse et ça ça
prend combien de temps réduire une chose
comme celle là chaque portion peut-être
cinq minutes ci s'est réduit la sauce
est caramélisée était comme ma soyeuse
[Rires]
[Musique]
selon suzanne certains plats de général
tao sont trop sucrés
elle a adapté sa version en fonction de
cela c'est une bonne chose quand vous
mangez tout en sucre et il vaut toujours
balancé ça vous savez ça pour une
personne oui avec sourire parce que
l'étouffer se fait avec de l'eau et même
vous mangez tous assez pâle comme lou ça
c'est bon pour une famille de quatre ces
quatre portions ce que les pois chiches
c'est nourrissant savard de rien mais
ces protéines et de défis j'ai une image
de femme au lard c'est ce que le sucré
le salé
voilà pourquoi ce
[Rires]
[Musique]